hello everybody hope they are good
what's going on with Bitcoin yesterday
we had CPI data plus inflation report it
came lower than expected the inflation
is coming down that's good news for
Bitcoin bad news for a dollar today we
had PPI data that's another different uh
report for inflation he also came lower
than expected which is good you know
we're having two days in a row positive
news regarding inflation
but what it's Bitcoin doing it's not
even reacting to it okay
um I was telling you yesterday that the
most likely thing was to see some kind
of a false move I was expecting this
first move to be to the downside first
um it was to the upside with this week
okay
um this could be a surprise this move
here uh we're gonna talk about it now
but this is structure this happens in
every single volatile news announcement
okay and I'm gonna go through it now
usually you see some kind of a wick
that's the first move
then price reverses into the opposite
direction okay and leaves the quality
pulls behind you have these two large
red candles okay then what happens in
the same day usually or you know in the
next day as it's the case of today they
get retraced okay this one already here
got retraced and now this one it's on
the way to get retraced okay so it's
very likely that Bitcoin makes a move to
the upside today okay now
with the Positive CPI data report I was
expecting you know pretty much the
opposite thing going on okay because I
was expecting you know to see a force
move to the downside okay and then this
Force move to leave also liquidity pools
so then we could retrace them and also
go towards the week okay but you can see
that the story was very different so I
was wrong yesterday I didn't even say on
Twitter I'll tell you what I'm wrong I
have no trouble saying so okay but
Bitcoin this is true Bitcoin is lagging
now it's reacting okay
but Bitcoin it's login check out the
dollar Index okay let's get to the
learning this what's the other thing
that's doing it's believing okay the
dollar Index is bleeding why is Bitcoin
not reacting to this let's go to the SMP
okay SPX 500 let me go to Capital com
that's the one I like
if I'm not wrong what is it
um well I can't find device okay let's
go here
um look at this to the upside what is
bitcoin not reacting to this
okay because Bitcoin is usually the last
one to move but
you know I was surprised to be honest
that you know it was lagging that badly
I was expecting some kind of map to the
upside yesterday but it's coming today
guys uh so anybody
like me that was in too long yesterday
okay I entered along at the 4r50 I mean
let me go there
450 I mean then you know we lost it
here was just in a resistance and I was
like okay something is going on here it
doesn't make any sense
this you know this has to be then the
false move and then I had the idea that
this liquidity pulls here sorry
have to get retraced okay and now if you
even notice you have here beautiful
double information check this out okay
this is a double deformation guys
okay that's all the information then you
got the retrace to towards the 1 hour
50ma and also the mid-range and now this
is ready to go higher okay so that's why
today I'm favoring higher prices
okay so uh my long is at thirty thousand
four hundred thirty five
I've just checked before the video so
exactly you know was the the 50ma
um I held yesterday because the position
was quite small
I uh I was debating with myself if to
add position here at a loss to get a
better entry I did it at the end I just
uh held the trade
um you know I'm not recommending to held
a trade at a loss but you know I was
very confused I was saying why is this
coin not going up it doesn't make sense
the dollar is you know dropping very
heavily so that's what I think guys I
think that from here
go to the photo time frame we are above
the 50 EMA in the four-door time frame
we're above the mid-range we assist
their support in the one hour sorry in
the one hour we are also above the 50
May test it up support so we have here a
lot of support in this one here okay
that's why this one
was a good Zone to enter the trade okay
of course you know if you're interested
here at this stage here when you could
see the W formation forming you know you
got the best entry okay but
today at least I'm gonna favor higher
prices same as yesterday okay because I
think that Bitcoin is you know it's
lagging uh what worries me
I'm not gonna lie to you what worries me
is that if Bitcoin has lacked so much
okay now for example maybe the dollar
Index could you know uh retraced a bit
and go up or the SMP could retrace a bit
and go down how is Bitcoin going to
react to it
okay it's Bitcoin got unlock from that
move or is Bitcoin gonna drop
immediately and don't like that move
that's the only thing that it's uh of
concern so be careful with your stop
loss make sure you have a stop loss in
place because it's true that SMP and the
dollar index chart they both are a bit
of extended they are due to a retrace
and we still don't know how Bitcoins is
gonna react to it
okay but yeah I can reassure you that
the liquidity at the moment is uh mainly
to the upside okay why well mainly
because this week here hasn't been uh
filled yet okay do you have here the 50
of the week and the full week that week
hasn't been retraced yet so you know
that's uh
a course of concern for anybody that is
running shorts now of course and the
first one telling you there is a lot of
liquidity here too okay look at this
liquidity pools check out this
inefficiencies in the chart okay these
are gonna get filled sooner or later
that's my idea now is it possible that
Bitcoin goes first towards this 50 of
the week here
okay if there is enough momentum then
I've told you my target would be 100 of
the week and of course a deviation above
the rain size here okay so there will be
Aviation around here between 31 800 and
31 700 okay if you see a deviation here
and then Bitcoin gets back inside this
range so that's below 31 430 then
okay that's my plan
for midterm you know that's what I would
take a swing short and then I would you
know start targeting mid range the range
lows and a breakout below this range
okay of course I'm not dismissing the
idea that Bitcoin could still go higher
okay get out this range and do another
pump here but all this shown here
you know this is resistance okay when
we're around resistance but there are
plenty of resistances here also in
higher time frame so you have to be very
careful because at Aviation I mean if we
get a pump here even to 32 200.
and then we get back into the range I'll
take it as a deviation too okay just a
larger deviation but there are many many
resistances here I don't think Bitcoin
from here can go to 40K oh no I'm not
gonna talk about that okay but it's
possible that we get one last pump okay
I'm even favoring a pump to
um
at least 31 700 and then from here I'm
gonna start to look for potential
deviations
um zones to short okay of course I'm not
gonna jump into shortest way that's
about heavier you have to wait for
momentum to Pivot to the downside okay
but we'll talk about it when we get
there okay now let's go to High blow
Capital let's also check the other book
let's check where the liquidity is okay
this is high block Capital we're gonna
start by checking the open interest
profile okay
um here uh basically what I take into
consideration are these longer spikes
they're gonna act as resistance and
support and also this gaps here okay you
have yoga 31k another go up on another
Gap sorry around 31 250. okay this gaps
act as magnetic zones okay that means
the price usually tends to move towards
these zones to fill this space here so
orders can open here okay they can
trigger limit orders and by that you
know they're gonna bring more liquidity
into the chart okay that then they can
hold later on with the liquidation so
the open interest profile at least in
the seven days time frame okay is also
going to help us to uh favor prices to
the upside towards 31k and 31 250. now
if you go into the liquidation heat map
okay let's have a look what is going on
here 12 hours time frame let's see if we
see something interesting here
okay
um the brightest bar is going to be 31
000 25
here also thirty thousand seven hundred
fifty that is quite of liquidity to the
downside also I know I lie to you but
in the 12 hours time frame I usually go
with the brightness bar okay and that's
a 31k too so
this could favor the idea that it's
possible that today we could see 31k now
seven days time frame
here what gets my attention is that
we are right between two massive
liquidation zones okay to the upside you
know we've had this one for a long time
31 350 and 31 250.
so this one here there is a lot of
liquidity but we've been having a lot of
liquidity here for a long time okay
sincere now with this Spike here it
created more liquidity okay more
liquidations so again could this be a
trick from the market maker this is a
spike here and then the retrace just to
you know build more liquidity at the
highest levels okay that was yesterday
with the CPI by the way this could
justify the false move to the upside
yesterday and their drop okay I think
yes
visual summonses with the week in my
chart in the four hour time frame so 31
350 should be taken sooner or later okay
that's what I think that's what I'm
going for of course you have liquid to
the downside twenty nine thousand six
hundred fifty this is uh basically
around the the range lows okay around
the range lows and here I drop
you know below the range loss could be a
deviation twenty nine thousand two
hundred but here do not thinking that
this is Pike here could have been
only to increase the liquidity here
yesterday with the CPI
I'm gonna favor all two in the seven
days time frame that we take this
liquidation Zone first okay a thirty one
thousand two hundred fifty Thirty one
thousand three hundred fifty uh of
course I might be wrong with this one
and if so I'll tell you I'm wrong but
that's what I think also one month time
frame but when I check it out
liquidations on here
check this out
31 700 is still a lot of liquidity here
and it keeps increasing okay uh that's
why I'm telling you about the potential
deviation above the range highs okay
because also if you notice you know when
we hit Thirty One Thousand seven hundred
you know it's probably gonna make Thirty
One Thousand eight hundred the next
level also turn into a yellow bar okay
because yeah there is also a lot of
liquidity already okay so potentially
they would you know aim for a deviation
a bit higher than thirty one thousand
seven hundred maybe Thirty One Thousand
well I would say between Thirty One
Thousand seven hundred and probably 32k
versus psychological number okay so
that's what I'm gonna look into uh
deviation above here then get back
inside the range and then that's what
I'm gonna short if we get that scenario
okay
so that's pretty much what high blood
capital is telling me we're gonna go now
into the order book let's check what the
order book is saying where we can see
more liquidity okay this is the other
book this is what the other book looks
like at the moment and you have to guide
yourself but do Sprite red bars okay and
also the right you can see the amount of
Bitcoin stuck in those levels in forms
of limit orders
liquidation levels and stop losses
because all of those are orders and
they're gonna be present in the order
book okay so you know that's kind of
like the big uh description of liquidity
okay all of those that are set limit
orders stop losses and liquidations
therefore what we call liquidity okay so
000 you can see 323 Bitcoins
okay in forms of short liquidations sort
limit orders and also stop losses okay
so that's the Zone in the chart if you
check I would favor it also to the
upside in this chart okay I think that
you know you can see price making a move
to the upside we have more liquidity to
the opposite also and it seems that
price is trying to Target those zones in
the chart okay 31k also notice how
around 31
550 I would say or 500 there's also a
lot of liquidity okay that could be your
deviation again all right so based on
another book
I also have to favor higher prices it
seems that everything is matching up
okay guys we're back into Bitcoin is two
o'clock UTC time then your session is
gonna start now we'll probably get some
kind of a stop right at the start of the
session okay a force move we're gonna
see what they do but in general terms by
looking at the chart
support here okay I also see a potential
double Reformation here
okay
and uh then based on high block Capital
as equal liquidity at 31k and based
another book also okay so in general
terms I'm going to favor higher prices
uh my long is from here 30 435 I think I
I think I said it was so uh that will be
around here probably matches with the
four hour time from 50ma
let's see how it does okay again it's
not it's a quite a small size
it seems that Bitcoin is still lagging
quite a lot so I'm just a bit cautious
what's going to happen when the dollar
Index and the SMP
retrace a bit
okay I'm Gonna Be Wondering if Bitcoin
is when I retrace with it or it's gonna
continue lagging and then you can
finalize the move to the upside before
another retrace okay so that's what I
mean guys uh be careful your trading
today also I was saying based on Hublot
capital A lot of liquidity at 31k I'm
based on the book also okay so that's
what I mean we could see some kind of
other information retrace with hata then
another boom then we could see another
retrace and then finalize the move in
this Zone here okay of course then you
have the 50 of the week but who knows
they're taking quite a long time to get
there so maybe they leave the for next
week okay guys uh for now I'll tell you
if you are trading today
um Bitcoin is quite slow so there might
be more opportunities even in the Forex
Market or in the stock market up by the
way I'm thinking
should I start to film videos talking
about the Forex
um the Forex market and the stock market
or you guys are all interested in crypto
okay because yeah I can I can also trade
Forex on the stock market so
um I wonder what you guys prefer
thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you soon